disturbing in serious allegations  emerging Tuesday morning against bills  running back LeSean McCoy on social  media a photograph of a woman with  severe facial injuries and an allegation  that McCoy is responsible for them  McCoy taking to social media to deny the  allegations very strongly and  aggressively calling them false and  saying he's had no contact with the  persons involved in those photos in  months which really does make it easier  to get to the bottom of this one if it's  provable that LeSean McCoy really hasn't  been around the alleged victim or anyone  making these claims against him in  recent months it's impossible that he  could have inflicted the injuries so  that becomes a fairly easy litmus test  for determining quickly whether or not  there's anything to this they are  serious allegations but they are merely  allegations McCoy has denied them and  now it should be fairly easy to get to  the truth  you